[Music]
on this Sunday night from Edmonton The
Final Countdown to the Alberta election
the last appeals to voters people here
pay attention what's at stake for the
two leaders and we dig into our latest
polling just released showing how tight
a race it could be turkey's president
claims victory in a close race erdogan
extends his 20 years of increasingly
authoritarian rule
escalation in Ukraine
Russia unleashes a major air attack on
key
plus a high-profile endorsement in
Alberta something about this incarnation
of this person scares me why Calgary's
former mayor believes Danielle Smith is
an existential threat to the province
Donna freeze
free tonight from Edmonton
good evening thanks for joining us we'll
get to the Alberta election in just a
moment but we begin with an out of
control Wildfire on the edge of Halifax
police say it has engulfed multiple
homes in the municipality of tantalan
that's about half an hour west of
Halifax a number of fire Crews have been
called in to help thousands of people
have been told to leave their homes in
multiple communities in the region
we do not have this fire under control
and we are receiving reports from our
Frontline firefighters that this fire is
still moving
the fire is taken off because it's 31
degrees in Halifax today and after a
very dry spring and winds gusting at 60
kilometers an hour that fire is burning
fast now to Alberta we are in Edmonton
on the last day of campaigning before
the provincial election that if the
opinion polls are accurate could be
tight the latest episodes polling done
for Global News gives Danielle Smith's
United conservatives an overall Edge
province-wide ahead by five percentage
points over Rachel nutley's new
Democrats in Calgary home of the most
competitive seats the two parties appear
tied we'll dig into our polling in just
a moment the leaders are in a final push
for support notly met supporters in Red
Deer in Edmonton promising to improve
health care education and deliver a more
reliable government Smith ran the 5K
race at the Calgary Marathon today the
populist conservative and former talk
radio host has warned re-electing the
NDP would be too costly for albertans
nowhere is the race Co closer right now
than in Battleground Calgary especially
in the Suburban neighborhoods of the
city's South Heather urich's West spent
the day door knocking in two key
writings
Glenmore Trail it's a busy Calgary
thoroughfare on any given day and to the
South you'll find the writings that hold
Alberta's political fate the NDP is
already going to win the seats in
Northeast Calgary in the downtown core
and parts of the Northwest uh
surrounding the University of Calgary
there's a lot of seats south of Glenmore
Trail therefore that's where they have
to to penetrate hi it's najwan with
Albert NDP how are you how are you doing
good najwan al-janet is a first-time
candidate for the NDP trying to flip the
riding of Calgary Glenmore
I have spent the last 15 years in the
energy sector people here pay attention
they have many questions the number one
concern so far that I've noticed is
Healthcare and the stat of the status of
our health care System I'm a little
frustrated with both parties to be
honest in the end it's uh
he's just closer to where I stand for so
well I'm glad to hear good morning
Healthcare is a key focus in the
neighboring riding of Calgary Acadia 2
where the ndp's Diana Batten a
registered nurse is taking on Tyler
shandro a former Health Minister for the
UCP going up against a health minister
or not I'm I'm here to provide a choice
of different type of support for Calgary
Acadia and they've been incredibly
receptive to it now we did reach out to
the UCP candidates for both Calgary
Glenmore and Acadia but neither the
teams for Tyler shandro or Whitney Isaac
responded to our request so in the
interests of balance we thought we would
do some door knocking of our own so you
go to Tyler shandro sign yeah what
appeals to you this selection about
Chandra I saw what the NDP did last time
and yeah it was atrocious I'm not a fan
of either party but right now it's a
lesser of two evils if the lawn signs
tell the story the race in these
writings appears incredibly tight a
Bellwether perhaps for what's to come
Monday in a race that could go either
way Heather urich's West Global News
Calgary
we had Rachel notley's NDP won the
election here in 2015 it ended Decades
of conservative rule but four years
later she lost to the new United
conservative party another elect in that
election the NDP won just 24 of
Alberta's 87 seats the UCP won 63s and
to win this time the NDB has to gain 20
seats while the UCP could lose 19 and
still win
With Me Now from Calgary as our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes
for the NDP to win it is going to be a
big climb what do you see in our latest
polling numbers
well Donna our latest polling numbers
show that the race remains very tight
but the polling firm says that the UCP
could be knocking on the door of a
majority they have managed to recover
some support let's break down the
numbers in some of the key areas
starting with where you are in Edmonton
in Edmonton the polling shows that 57
percent of Voters are prepared to vote
for the NDP that's who they're leaning
towards heading into election day while
40 percent say the UCP that puts the NDP
at 17 points ahead in rural areas the
UCP has a huge Advantage 65 percent say
that they are leaning towards the UCP
while 31 percent say the NDP that is a
lead of 34 points for the UCP now in
Battleground Calgary where I am the city
that is expected to decide this election
absolutely neck and neck a literal
statistical tie 49 UCP 49 NDP so Donna
very very tight heading into the end of
this race the UCP has managed to recover
some voters who are women there is now
an even split between them and there is
an increasing split between those who
say there should or should not be change
in the government that it's time for
that the UCP has managed to regain some
support there on folks who feel that
maybe they're willing to give them a
second chance Mercedes we know there's a
history of holes getting things wrong
they should be treated with some
skepticism how much do we know about the
undecided and the possible vote
switchers people who say they're
conservative but they intend to vote NDP
this time so this is the big risk for
the conservatives and it's not just
whether or not they vote NDP it's
whether they simply stay home I've
talked to a lot of well-known
conservatives out here who tell me they
don't know if they're going to vote for
Danielle Smith and while they might not
be prepared to cast a vote for Rachel
notley they might just stay in their
house and if that happens that is a risk
to the UCP in some of these very tight
ridings and it's something that's often
not captured in polls we've seen polls
be wrong in Alberta before we don't know
about this one but it'd be interesting
to see just how honest people have been
with pollsters and we've seen little of
Danielle Smith this weekend she doesn't
seem to have been out campaigning or she
is it's under the radar how unusual is
that for a leader just before the vote
so it's not unusual for them to not talk
to us in the media but it is unusual for
them not to be out trying to show big
crowds but that can be a tactic that's
used if a campaign believes their leader
is a liability and not an asset and one
of the things that I've heard from UCP
candidates going door to door here is
that they've been trying to convince
people vote for me because I'm the
incumbent versus vote for the leader
because they say a lot of people are
telling them they're not big fans of
Danielle Smith
okay Mercedes Stevenson in Calgary
thanks
voters in Turkey have decided to stay
with the man who led an increasingly
totalitarian government for 20 years
receipt erdogan has been declared winner
of the runoff election Redmond Shannon
looks at how he did it and what it could
mean for turkey's future
[Music]
celebration chorus from turkey's
recipient
declaring victory for five more years as
president erdogan's latest success is
remarkable after 20 years in power as
prime minister and then president he
faced criticism for the handling of
February's deadly earthquakes and for
his controversial strategy of lowering
interest rates to tackle inflation it
still sits at 44 because it goes against
all common sense it goes against you
know if the political science people
would say then how did this happen well
yes once again a strong turkey the
issues that we identity erdogan's
identity politics is rooted in religion
and tradition railing against LGBT
rights and cracking down on Independent
Media with thousands of political
opponents arrested or jailed I think
turkey is going to continue that
illiberal turn that we're seeing across
the world whether it's in Hungary and
Poland the defeated secularist
had tried to court the Nationalist vote
in the days leading up to the runoff
echoing erdogan by promising to deport
some of turkey's millions of Syrian
refugees erdogan's foreign policy will
likely continue to mirror the geography
of turkey straddling East and West the
NATO member state provides arms to
Ukraine but erdogan is close to Vladimir
Putin and he has been Keen to act as a
mediator in the conflict on the other
side of the Black Sea Redmond Shannon
Global News London
ring out over Ukraine's Capital as
Russia unleashes a wave of airstrikes
whoever wins the election tomorrow will
occupy the premier's office here at the
Alberta legislature in Edmonton we're
back in a moment
[Music]
to the war in Ukraine now the country's
capital has endured Russia's largest
drone attack of the invasion for hours
more than 50 iranian-made drones
targeted Kiev according to defense
officials most of them were shot down
but one person was killed Sharia Israeli
reports
Sirens rang out in the Ukrainian Capital
as drones swarmed the city
the explosions echoed for hours while
Russia Unleashed drone strike after
drone strike
the biggest attack of its kind since the
start of the war
something started to explode above us as
this woman the children began running in
fear the onslaught killed a 41 year old
man and sent a 35-year-old woman to
hospital it also damaged the Ukrainian
Society of the blind
they would come here to chat says this
member this was like their home the
Ukrainian Air Force says it shot down
more than 50 iranian-made drones
The Raid coincided with kieve day which
marks the city's founding almost 1600
years ago what Russia is trying to do in
all this is to try and drain Ukrainian
air defense uh missiles ahead of its
anticipated highly anticipated spring
counter offensive a top Ukrainian
security official wouldn't name a date
but insisted that counter-offensive is
imminent the Kremlin issued its own
warning in an interview with the BBC
Russia's ambassador to the UK says
Moscow has not started to act seriously
yet in Ukraine it's a big
idealistic mistake to think that Ukraine
may prevail this is just Bluster and
bravado and um
that's all it is Russia's Ally Iran has
provided Moscow with weapons throughout
the conflict like the drones used in
this latest attack as a result Ukraine's
president wants to slap sanctions on the
Iranian regime for 50 years
rate Global News Ottawa
in the U.S Democrats and Republicans
have reached a tentative debt ceiling
deal to raise the federal government's
31.4 trillion dollar borrowing limit
just days before a possible default top
Congressional Republican Kevin McCarthy
struck a deal with President Joe Biden
late yesterday details are still being
ironed out but it suspends the debt
ceiling until January 2025 it boosts
defense spending and cap spending for
many discretionary domestic programs a
vote is expected in the house as early
as Wednesday
show of support ahead why Calgary's
former mayor has gone public with his
endorsement in the Alberta election
you're looking at Calgary's Heritage
Park on the banks of the Glenmore
Reservoir and the Elbow River we're back
from Alberta in a moment
[Music]
there have been a couple of big late
stage endorsements in the Alberta
election campaign former conservative
Prime Minister Stephen Harper put out
this video
there's only one option to protect the
economic livelihoods of you and your
family that's Danielle Smith and the
United conservative party
and former Calgary mayor now had Nancy
endorsed NDP leader Rachel notley even
showing up at a campaign event with her
in the past he's been careful not to
publicly back any party this time he
told me he couldn't remain silent
the reason I did this is because on
balance this election has to be about
trust
and it has to be about leadership and it
has to be about confidence
the stakes have never been higher
and the challenge is not
if Danielle Smith wins wins will she
implement the UCP platform that's fine
the question is which Danielle Smith
will show up to work and the one that
has been way off of the UCP platform
frankly scares me a little bit so will
we get the Danielle Smith who has had
years and years of speaking out against
people who may not fit in the mainstream
we've had a Danielle Smith who has spent
her entire career talking about how
people should have to pay for health
care to reduce the demand for public
health care who now says no no no I
didn't don't listen to what I said yes
well she says don't listen to what I
said before so what do you make of that
what that said to me was I've got no
core I've got no ethics I've got nothing
that I stand for I will just do whatever
is politically popular she'll be elected
with people who've come from an
organization called take back Alberta
and they never answer the question take
it back from whom exactly for people
watching this across the country who
don't know take back Alberta can you
concisely tell people what think manga
think Trump
and so I'm nervous that her caucus is
made up of these folks you know think of
Kevin McCarthy in the United States he
won the narrowest of Victories but
instead of using that as a lesson to be
more moderate he actually allowed the
radical right to pull his strengths and
that's what you're afraid would happen
here there's a difference though where
Kevin McCarthy is happy to have Marjorie
Taylor green pull his strings in this
scenario Danielle Smith is Marjorie
Taylor green you you have said that
Danielle Smith is an existential threat
to the province that's that those are
that's big words those are big words a
lot of syllables but yeah I know that
was hard for me to say because I've
known Danielle for 30 years but
something about this incarnation of this
person scares me scares you because
you're I don't know what she's gonna do
what is Rachel not Lee's biggest
vulnerability do you think I was the
mayor when she was Premier I worked with
her very closely I didn't love it
I didn't think she was the best Premier
I ever worked with and there were lots
of things that we really disagreed on
so but I think she can defend her record
by simply saying I had your best
interests at heart and yes I took office
during a terrible Global recession but
there were more jobs in Alberta at the
end than there were at the beginning but
she's allowed herself to be defined on
the economy
in a way that gets a lot of people
across the river here who work in oil
and gas nervous so you've endorsed the
NDP how many conservatives in this
province do you think who maybe can't
bring themselves to vote for Danielle
Smith
we'll vote NDP that's the core question
of this election what are those people
going to do and I call it the hold your
nose choices
will they hold their nose and vote for
Danielle Smith and believe their UCP
candidate who says don't worry we'll get
rid of her after the election do they
hold their nose and just stay home
and we're hearing a lot of that but then
I'll look for a lot of folks that's well
that's like making other letting other
people make the choice for me or do they
hold their nose and vote for Rachel But
ultimately I don't know but which of
those three nose holding things they do
is what besides the election thank you
thank you
[Music]
who to trust next I talked to some
albertans about what they're
contemplating in this election
welcome back to Edmonton for decades the
conservatives have ruled Alberta there's
only been an NDP government once so in
theory this election should be an easy
win for Daniel Smith's United
conservatives but if the polls are right
it's a tight race the question is can
the NDP win over enough moderate
conservatives what we used to call
Progressive conservatives who just can't
bring themselves to support Danielle
Smith I spoke with some albertans to get
their thoughts
there's lots of bull at the Foothills
cattle auction in stavely Alberta
thousands of head of livestock are
bought and sold here and though prices
fluctuate not much else has changed so
that's the beginning of the Foothills
right there and Rob bergevan has run
this place for two decades I'm hoping
that that the ECP I believe that their
platform may have more economic benefit
to small businesses like ours it's Ranch
Country and like the rest of rural
Alberta conservative country finding an
NDP are here is as likely as finding a
farmer without a hat everyone we spoke
to said they'd vote UCP but praise for
leader Danielle Smith was mostly muted I
find it difficult to trust politicians I
I think that there's a lot of verbiage
that's being spilled out of their mouths
as they're trying to get elected and
then some of those things don't come to
fruition just a little nervous what are
you nervous about who's going to get in
this couple says they hope the NDP lose
but well we can't trust either of them
really can we seen a politician you
could
I've listened to your talk shows and
stuff like this and I mean sometimes the
hardest thing
you know to do to appease an audiences
tell the truth
you know and and sometimes maybe you
know comes in a little hot on the truth
but the truth is still the truth head to
Calgary and NDP supporters are easier to
find though the ones we talk to don't
sound overlay enthusiastic either when I
say Danielle Smith what do you think
she's not my particular cup of tea
and when I say Rachel notley what do you
think
I feel more optimistic uh when when you
mention her this couple says they
support the UCP but the leader when I
say Danielle Smith to you what do you
think
well you know
I wish she wouldn't talk so much so your
voting sounds like more for the party
than for the leader more for the
partiness definitely one of the big
unknowns is how many conservatives can
stomach Danielle Smith you're not sure
you can vote conservative again that's
right why is that
um I think the leader is Extreme in
certain areas in my opinion
on the other hand I'm kind of more
aligned with her economically so I'm
just kind of weighing weighing that out
in my head
that's the only way the NDP have a
chance of winning if conservatives stay
home or switch their vote but I think
this time we're going to go for the NDP
last weekend we uh we spent time with
um eight nine or ten individuals who are
all traditionally conservative and these
are all business professionals senior
Executives have always voted
conservative and none of them is going
to vote for the conservative party this
year we think they're kind of following
uh our friends South of the Border their
friends not our friends Trump like he
thinks vote switchers though are a
minority that the UCP is likely to win
back at the cattle auction Rob bergervan
says the bottom line is pretty simple
whoever wins must focus on economic
Prosperity we want people to eat beef
and you can't afford beef if you're not
working so
and that is global national for this
Sunday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
candidate is the Edmonton Skyline we'll
be back here for election day in Alberta
for now thanks for watching and hope to
see you again tomorrow bye-bye
foreign